so above this dotted line I have a
certain number of boxes and we could see
each of these gold bars they have ten
boxes in a one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten and I have two
groups of these tens so I have two tens
I have two tens and I have one two three
ones that's how many boxes I have above
that line and below that line I have one
two three four tens four tens and I have
one two three four five I have five ones
so this first number is two tens and
three ones or 23 two tens three ones the
second number is four tens and five ones
four tens and five ones 45 now what I
want to do is add the numbers so let's
do that let's add so let's add that
amount this amount to this amount
twenty-three to forty-five well I have
three ones here I have five ones here so
if you add those two those you're going
to end up with eight ones so let me do
that in that blue color so you're going
to have one two three four five six
seven eight and if we look at over if we
look at it over here where we write down
the numbers with with digits or the
numerals then here you're going to have
three ones plus 5 ones is eight ones
eight ones eight ones now you have two
tens plus four tens well that's going to
be six tens so let me actually copy and
paste this so I have two tens so 2 plus
4 is 6 so 2 4 + 2 4 and 6 so I have I
have let me change my tool so I have 1 2
3 4 5 6 tens whoops using the wrong
thing
I have I have six tens so just like that
you can see when I add 23 to 45 I just
added the ones place three plus five was
eight three plus five is eight three
ones plus 5 ones is eight ones and I
ended the tens place two tens plus four
tens is equal to six tens so I got 68